Maureen's gift of 5,000 pound for local
projects is open for applications in
memory of Maureen Vince a roach for
community champion Maureen's gift offers
financial support for local voluntary
and charitable organizations to deliver
projects that keep the community
thriving your project may include
helping older people and those with it
is with disabilities equipment for art
groups and play groups supporting people
back into work or tackling anti-social
behavior for an application pack contact
virtual housing on 0800 0121 double nine
one or zero one seven zero to five
double 3461 or email get involved that's
one word dot Rochford at sanctuary
hyphen housing code UK quoting Maureen's
gift the closing date for applications
is the 31st March 2012
rochford district matters is edited by
patrick john and produced by rockford
district council who can be found at
three to nineteen south street rochford
SS for one BW their telephone number is
zero one seven zero to five four six
three six six and their website is at w
wh food gov UK Rochford district matters
is printed by Charmin and company
limited and that brings us to the end of
this edition which was recorded by
volunteers from the rayleigh Rochford
and castle point talking newspapers for
the blind at their studio in rockford